everyone not a typical numberphile video
for obvious reasons Ben sparks who
ironically is the person who lives
closest to me he's only about 40 miles
I think he's that way but he's at home
at the moment so am i but we're gonna
have a talk via technology hopefully and
what are we talking about Ben what are
we gonna try and discuss I think there's
a lot of videos and chat out there about
how mathematicians are modeling this
spread of the co mid-nineteen virus and
it's kind of like this sort of halcyon
days for mathematical modelers despite
it being a horrible circumstance
everybody is queuing up to ask the
mathematicians opinion on what's going
to happen next and I guess it's a shout
out mathematical modeling is what helps
us predict what happens in the world it
generally what I wanted to show you was
a way of using one of the standard
models of disease spread on a free piece
of software that people can just try
themselves and see that the modeling
that people are doing to predict this is
it's kind of accessible I see you've got
the honorary brown paper needs must
we've got to do something properly
numberphile I actually don't have any
physical brown paper I could find so I
had to you know get a screen grab of
brown paper and put it in geogebra which
I'm going to use to show you a model of
a disease spread I hope that is that an
image taken from an actual number files
an actual mobile phone brown paper yet I
mean spared no expense here so I've got
to try and build you a mathematical file
in this program called jobra which
anyone can try and follow along with the
program spree so grab it if you want to
try it the the three variables I'm going
to use a written on the screen already
and just check and you can see that all
right I've got a s for susceptible
meaning a bunch of people that are
possibly able to get a ZZZ ifer infected
people who have got the disease and are
for recovered by which I mean are not
infected anymore to be honest that
doesn't necessarily mean recovered right
that they may be dead which means
they're not going to be infectious
anymore and that's the sad truth of
modeling diseases like this is that
there are two ways out you recover or
you don't
but either way you stop infecting people
I'm gonna I'm gonna use our for recover
some people call it removed but I will
forget to say that word Sony's recovered
as long as you
I mean and we're gonna build up like all
good mathematical models some sort of
simple almost naive assumptions of how
diseases spread and follow the
mathematical consequences of those
simple things just to make a prediction
and and actually judge will do a big the
lifting and heavy lifting for us so
happy for me let's start chattin maths
okay I'm gonna set up a population of
size 1 this sounds a little bit
confusing and I'm typing into the top
and thing here n equals 1 which is mean
I'm using like my entire population to
mean like 100% so zero to one measures
some fraction of the population and the
whole population is size one you can do
these models with a large number but it
everything just scale so I'm just going
to go with between 0 and 1 which is why
my graph is 0 and 1 about here on the
screen I'm also going to set up some
initial setup so presumably there are
some infected people in my population
otherwise you're gonna be asking why
we're doing the model so I'm gonna start
some values of infected and susceptible
and recovered and the infected I'm going
to call I start not meaning me starting
I mean the number of infected people at
the start of this I'm going to call 1%
which is 0.01 and I get there everyone
else is therefore susceptible so those
susceptible people to start is gonna be
and the total number of people take away
I start and I think it's just 99% less
susceptible that's because no one of
this stage has recovered so our start is
0 and those are like my initial
conditions for a model here looks a bit
cryptic and basically programming in
maths I'm gonna set up to 3 more
variables in fact which we use in a
minute and you'll feel a bit arcane
until you realize why but I'm gonna use
sliders for this and there's a slider
tool here
I'm just gonna put it here this slider
is gonna represent how quickly does this
disease gets transmitted like you
infection rate so I'm making a slider I
won't do anything yet but you can see I
can change this number it's gonna be
something to do with how quickly infects
people and get another slider for how
quickly people recover from this disease
which is gonna be smaller because it
takes a while to recover from diseases
otherwise they usually don't really
register in any mortal what are the
units of time here bear it doesn't
actually matter
we said we could pick it you know and
run with it let's say days but I'm not
necessarily gonna have the numbers right
to model this in days but then if you
change the unit of time you just have to
change these parameters to reflect that
and we can do some because there aren't
sliders we can do the playing realm that
later on to see if we can change the
units okay and at the moment they're
called a and B a and B yeah do you all
me too I think I can give him different
names if you like just to really help
promote me remember what they are well
yeah let's rename it let's call this
transmission
it was quite trans all coding has to
have horrible names right but I still
have type in really long names all the
time let's call it recover so I've got a
transmission rate and a recovery rate
and I'm gonna use them to build some
naive models one more parameter I need
which is how long I'm gonna let the
model run for you'll see why this is
useful later I'm gonna call it the max
time I'm gonna go up to about 20 flow
okay good now we're into the real matter
what I'm gonna do is set up three what
they call differential equations which
sounds scarier than it should but these
are equations which tell us the sort of
naive assumptions we're going to make
about these three numbers what I want to
know in the end is what these numbers
are over time how many susceptible how
many are infected and how many are
recovered but what I can't tell you is
straight away what those numbers are I
can guess though how quickly they're
going to change depending on various
things so I'm going to write down three
equations which tell me about the rate
of change of these things the first one
is called s - I'm gonna call it s - and
that is sort of mathematical code for it
if you were gonna write it longhand
maybe dsdt if you know any calculus
that's the derivative of s with respect
to time but in everyday language is the
rate of change of the number of
susceptible people how quickly it's
changing and it's gonna depend on time
so this bit looks a technical but I'm
typing in a bunch of variables the rate
of change of centrifugal depends on time
and the number of susceptibles and the
number of effectives and the number of
cupboards all of these things might
affect that but in practice and here
this is the first time we actually get
some matter in on the screen the rate of
change of susceptibles is negative
because the number of susceptible will
go down because they're getting infected
does that bit make sense and we're
working on this assumption that once
you've been infected
if you've recovered or died you can't
get
again yeah we are assuming in this
particular model of disease that once
you've infected and recovered you are
now sort of immune in some sense so you
don't become susceptible again the thing
is the if you've got loads of
susceptible people and a few infected
people at first anyway the susceptible
people go down so what I'm expecting
here is a negative rate of change which
is arriving a negative sign at the top
of the screen there and it's going to
depend on three things what is the
parameter a which I've called trans now
trans the transmission rate and if that
will also depend on how many people are
susceptible so if there's lots of
susceptible people you can imagine we're
gonna lose them to be infections quite
quickly and also depend on how many
infected people are so this is
relatively simple there's a number the
transmission rate multiplied by the
susceptible people multiplied by the
infected people and it's negative
because the susceptible people are going
down they're gonna turn into infected
people so there's my first equation it's
a differential equation it's a rate
equation that's what means it by a
differential equation we need to do two
more for the other two variables and
it's not too bad so I'm gonna go with I
next I - is gonna depend on the the same
four possibilities here but this time
the first was obvious because if people
were susceptible and that's where this
first equation we typed in was capturing
they're going to become infected next so
everything that's gone away from
susceptible has become infected so it's
exactly the same as what I just wrote
down but this time positive so you can
see it's the same thing transmission
rate times s times I but this time it's
not got a negative sign because the
infected people are going up presumably
if they're moving from susceptible to
infected however I hope we are aware
that some people can recover and so that
will cause the number infected to go
down so I need a negative bit and this
is where the recovery becomes in that
corner to recover for their right and
that will depend on how many people are
infected the more people infected the
more people that can recover obviously
and a certain rate so that's got the
high number in there as well I notice
you're not attaching any like weightings
or anything to these two these numbers
no it all seems like really what 110
there are two weightings the two
weightings are these precise numbers
transmen transmission rate and recovery
rate so there are weightings but i'm
trying to keep the model simple
this moment it's 3.2 and that'll affect
how many people are going to move from
susceptible to infected and the recovery
rate is going to affect how many people
move from infected to recovered so those
are the waiting's if you like but
they're the only parameters and this is
the thing with models you you start
simple and you realize that even simple
models can capture behavior and then you
upgrade the models which will be a whole
week's course instead of a single video
let's do one more equation which is the
R - the rate of change of recovered
people so the same four variables in
here and this time it's a simple end
again because anyone who's infected and
now recovered is going to move into this
category
so it's precisely the term I just had at
the end of the infected rate but this
time positive so the recov multiplied by
the number of affected so actually there
are only two terms in this there's the
negative version in the susceptible to
infected one then again some negative
there and positive there and then the
effective one you've got in the negative
people that's recovering from infected -
recovered so again something up negative
there and positive there so that was
that that was the hard way and that's
that's the modeling bit that's what
mathematicians get paid for to come up
with these models to be honest they're
not rocket science they're sensible
guesses and how things might behave
solving these equations is a different
matter before we do that I'm just going
to change the color so we keep track of
this susceptible we made blue infected
we had a sort of brownie red and
recovered let's go with green is that
all right can you see those colors okay
bins color blue and by the way people
which is why he's asking me Brady about
is that actually red anyway we're gonna
go with this we've got a brownie red
infected color which is yeah yeah so if
you want to solve differential equations
then you need to go and study some
serious math and I'm not here to teach
you to solve differential equations
what's nice about mathematicians is that
they have programmed computers to do
numerical solution just like a
calculator can solve equations for you
George Abra here can solve differential
equations so I got type in here command
called n sold in fact known as n sold o
de the OD e stands for ordinary
differential equation mathematicians are
as bad as everyone else at coming up
with that craniums than no one
recognizes but ordinary differential
equation in this case is
system of three differential equations
and this command is just gonna spit out
the solution so this is the exciting bit
you just get to type it in and it will
should do all the work for us first of
all I need a list of derivatives and
that's the three things I just typed in
these are rate equations or derivatives
in jej we need curly brackets for a list
so it's s - I called it and then I
dashed and then are dashed close that
list it asks for the initial
x-coordinate and on our scale x-axis is
time so we're gonna start time zero and
we will a list of initial y coordinates
or in this case the initial values of
our three functions and those are the
things I set up at the very beginning so
let's go in the same order s start the
number of people starting susceptible
and then I start I think into the older
and then par start finally I need a
final x-coordinate and this is why I set
up a max time thing because it's gonna
tell me how long to go on the simulation
for now it's already done something
that's my command that's the sort of
magic of using a piece of software to
solve an equation for you if I had
returned it has done three things which
look kind of down here they don't look
very complete yet but can you see that
one ohms going down what I was going up
and woman's going up a little bit more
slowly is that they're all black well
sort out the colors because Jerry
doesn't do the colors for us and I wish
it did frankly for my own color vision
deficiency but I can also increase the
timing tap carries on so you can see
this is the important bit when I crank
up the time you see how these things
develop over time and actually be much
nicer to see this with color so let's
rewind that and put some colors on the
first one it's old is s so let's rename
that to be s and make it excitingly blue
I don't know why blue is exciting the
next one is our brownie red we know that
to be infected and finally we've got
recovered and that was a green can I
click it and finally let's just make
them nice and thick and now we can see I
could even just animate this and
right-click and animate it and you see
what happens to the numbers of
susceptible events and recovered over
time you may be of guessing what you
think will happen but let's just click
go
and so what I hope you're seeing is this
red graph has been in the news a lot
this bump of infected people which does
tale off again but it's nice that Jojo
is just doing this for us
you're going back in time now yeah yeah
I've got a change of properties of the
number here to stop it oscillating but
yeah you can go and tinker with this
yourself the that's what it starts with
the number susceptible goes down and in
fact it goes up and people do start
recovering enough of the effect is to
jump off but it's how high that bump is
is really what's causing all the
headlines at the moment cuz if that bump
of infected people the red bump that's
that that's when the infective infected
people is at its highest yeah red bump
is at its peak and according to this
model which is going between zero and
100 percent like almost 80% of the
population got it at once and that
that's obviously if you project that to
our NHS that's a problem which is what
which we've just started this week of
lockdown in the UK I mean it's
unprecedented because they're trying to
stop this bump from dominating the
entirety of all hospital intensive care
beds but now we've done it and this is
the nice thing about doing a model is
that we can change these parameters so I
said this we can flatten the curve we
can flatten the curve we can squash the
bubble whatever you want to call it and
there are two ways according to our
model right we let's crank up the time
so we've got enough model we can
decrease the transmission rate which
means like stop people from talking to
each other social distancing all that
stuff and if I start knocking that down
if I just kind of and I made that down
you can see what's happening to the
model layer as you lower the
transmission right that red bump so yes
look it's lower yeah and that means
there are fewer people all needing the
hospital at once exactly we're squashing
the bubble of beers flattening the curve
and that's kind of what we're trying to
do at the moment and you can see that
this model lets us try and see what how
much you have to do that and you see
that eventually if you reduce this rate
hugely not only do you flatten the curve
you also stop everyone from getting the
disease in the long run we we can crank
up the maximum time I may go off the
edge of our pre-arranged paper here but
let's just see what happens
crank up time and see see what we see
here so this is settled down now and not
everyone has the disease so maybe 10%
this blue line acceptable so there's
still 10% people susceptible in the long
run but they've never got the disease
and that is kind of what we're praying
for because some people won't survive
this disease and if we can stop at least
a lot maybe 10% of the most vulnerable
from getting it that'll be great
you see why reducing the transmission
rate doesn't just squash the curve it
also reduces the number people actually
gain the disease in the long run and of
course the vaccine may be developed in
them in the interim and in which case
the susceptible people can be made
susceptible you can take them out of the
equation entirely if you vaccinate them
I mean you can also increase the
recovery rate if you crank up the way
the people recover and you can see that
increasing their flattens the curve as
well but that's much harder to do the
NHS is doing that they're trying to keep
people healthy and recover quickly in
hospital but in practice we know that it
takes at least a week or so to get over
this thing and sometimes a lot longer
there aren't treatments or cures that
can really help us move that slider very
exactly yeah we're do our level best
obviously in the NHS but we can't
control it very well and what you might
have heard some people talking about on
the on the sort of chat shows about
modeling this stuff is something called
r0 which is the sort of rate of
infection is actually a comparison of
these two numbers so it's one divided by
the other if I'd if I do transmission
divided by Rik of that number let's just
crank it onto the screen there we should
call it r0 for the sake of yeah let's
call r0 that sounds sensible we know
it's confusing calling r0 sometimes
because it might also refer to the are
start which was anyway this is our zero
meaning some sort of reproduction rate
and you can see that we think they are
zero for the co bird 19 is about three
perhaps and it's kind of like a ratio of
these two things but this is possibly a
good model for our disease we're looking
at now and obviously we haven't sorted
out the units of time but even maybe
it's about right the number of days
might spike in about two weeks from when
things start off I'm not doing a phone
Narcis but you can see that even in a
free piece of software with three basic
differential equations it solves it for
you and you can
into get a predicting model that tells
us what's going to happen in the future
then the transmission rate like you're
you're moving it like a slider it's like
almost like an abstraction that yeah and
just play with yeah how do the modelers
go change that number based on things
like we're going to close the cinemas
we're going to close the schools we're
going to stop people we're going to keep
people in their house for two weeks or
three weeks how does how do those
real-world interactions turn into a
number number well this is where there's
a lot of argument out there in the press
right this is guesswork we don't know
what the transmission rate and recovery
times are they're not written in the
back of a textbook all we can do is
estimate them from the data we get from
say China who've been dealing with it
longer than the rest of the world so
which is why the data from China is
super valuable and also whether we why
we need to know whether we can trust it
so you go get data from China and then
maybe Italy and then maybe Iran and then
you ask serious questions about whether
that data is reliable to build your
models on and then you start saying what
if we social isolate maybe we can reduce
this by a certain amount and you have to
look at other studies that have been
done to see how much certain actions
will reduce that but it is guesswork
this is why having a model is super
important because you can't do the
guesswork live and wait to see if
everyone dies because that's just not
how things should run it one thing that
was absolutely clear though is no matter
what happened
whenever you slid to the transmission
down the the red the red bump flattened
yeah and it finds a lot even if we don't
know how much it's flattening it does
flatten it
absolutely and the more we can plan it
the better the actual details of exactly
what numbers we need to keep our society
safe is guesswork from everybody which
is why I mean the government has got a
difficult job and everybody is going to
be second guessing them including
experts including the experts that
they're relying on for their information
but it's important stuff and for once
you've got a listen to the
mathematicians because they're the only
ones with the access to this model to
predict what will happen oh and and
numberphile viewers now can make their
own model and numberphile videos because
they're all going to be making their own
model so there is a file I made earlier
which are this file here which I just
put a little animation on so you can see
the
his numbers tracking overtime and this
one I have left it as a and B but people
can make their own and come up with
their own labels on this and actually I
think realizing that the model is within
their own grasp is certainly it's kind
of useful for me I'm a mathematician but
I have to go and dig up my knowledge on
these things I think how do I program
this and it turns out to be not that
hard particularly if the computer will
do the grunt work of solving the things
for you then as a math guy as you've
been following this slight this pandemic
as it unfolds and the way it's been
covered in the media and social media
and things like that how have you felt
about the way that lay people are
grasping the mathematics and how well do
you think it's being explained I think
it's hard to explain well because like
all maths it needs a bit of a run-up
even in this description I've been
talking about differential equations if
you're not sure what a rate of change or
what differentiation is then that run-up
needs to happen to make you comfortable
with the rest of the explanation but the
number of people have been talking about
exponential growth logarithmic scales
which most numberphile viewers will be
familiar with it turns out they're
desperately important to discuss the
sort of epidemics that we're seeing so
it's been fascinating and sobering to
realize sometimes in our mathematical
world we think we live in these abstract
things but this is desperately important
in a very real-life way so that's both
exciting for me as a math educator like
people realise this is important and
sobering because it does seem to be the
crises when we notice that it's
important when everything is running
normally we don't really notice that
these models are important so in the
video description for this video I'm
going to put some links to some files
from been more stuff that you can tweak
and play around with I'm also going to
link to some other YouTube videos that
have been made by other creators that
are really good about what's going on
with coronavirus and the pandemic but
then I want you to stay inside and go
and wash your hands you too Brady get
that letter in the mail saying you have
tested positive for this disease if you
get that letter if you're anything like
me your stomach falls into your feet and
you start to worry a question that
mathematics can help us answer is how
worried do you really need to
maybe very worried maybe not at all